tenez est-ce que c'est très difficile
d'être la fille de missiles trêve ça me
donne pas cher du tout ça ne me donne
pas non plus davantage parce que il ya
beaucoup de comédiens qu'on l'a plus ou
moins physique facile ou difficile à
imposer et que le métier très très
difficile si maman connais des gens à ce
moment là bien sûr c'est plus agréable
de les rencontrer mais ça n'est pas un
avantage sur le travail sur une
possibilité de travailler
c'est un avantage de pontacq oui il faut
vous imposer après mais quand même ça
vous ouvre des portes sur non plus que
mademoiselle x ou y qui me connaît
personne
je sais pas j'ai pas l'impression j'ai
tellement mal de toute façon et j'ai
l'impression de tellement comme tous les
autres jeunes comédiens a essayé de
faire des choses à essayer de rencontrer
des gens et de toute façon tous les
contacts les rangs les rends compte que
je peux avoir avec des gens sont montés
tous très difficile parce qu'on est très
souvent mal reçus et bêtement ou
simplement on vous regarde regarde votre
tête envers nos jambes on veut dire vous
écrira jolie actu pas la pression de et
puis je dis pas toujours je suis la
filmer chez brel gère cette part est
alors la part landes
michel pas la mer est ce que vous avez
des contacts est ce qu'elle est là
en copine ou au contraire est-ce qu'elle
a été aux femmes je vais les avoir ni
mais quand vous étiez petite fille est
ce qu'elle est elle est sévère commenté
tél nous on était passés vers du tout on
a toujours eu des rapports très très
libre et très
formidable et les d'une mère mère parce
que
protège mais que je veux dire quand on
est plus ou moins bas où elle nouvelle
un espèce de grande force de protection
et puis c'est une amie parce qu'on rit
beaucoup ensemble et qu'on envie comme
deux amis mais c'est aussi maire est-ce
que vous avez les mêmes beaux points de
vue théâtre est ce que vous aimeriez
jouer je dis pas le rôle qu'elle a joué
depuis ce que vous dites vous-même n'est
pas le même emploi mais est-ce que vous
êtes toujours d'accord sur la façon dont
il a mené sa carrière
oh oui je pense que si elle l'a fait
c'est de toute façon elle avait de
bonnes raisons parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui a un pied très honnête qui a
beaucoup de bouées et qu'il l'a fait
avec entrent en jeu les difficultés
qu'elles pouvaient avoir les avantages
qu'ils pouvaient avoir est ce qu'il a
fait là bien fait
[Musique]